my talk at the table is about the highly
anticipated new film John Wick chapter
four The John Wick franchise starring
Keanu Reeves follows a retired Hitman
who's forced back into the underground
world of Assassins to face his enemies
the new sequel could break franchise box
office records this weekend its Cass
includes martial arts star Scott Adkins
he's known for roles in action films
like ipman 4 the finale with martial
arts Legend Donnie Yen he's also in John
Wick 4. he wore heavy makeup look at
this to play and it's a fast and name
Killa who meets John Wick at his
nightclub watch this
you want to kill him
I want to kill him
what about you Mr Vick
I'm going to kill you oh for better of
course yeah
but it looks like we have ourselves uh
genuine conundrum
like wondering if you will a real life
dilemma so
I thought we play a game
one hand
Savannah desires who lives
it does not
Atkins joins us first on CBS mornings
welcome yes welcome welcome it is so
good to see you first of all you're
basically playing a bond villain in that
scene right um yeah but but just you're
a big fan of the John Wick franchise uh
but when you got the call from the
director that he wanted you to be in
this film oh yeah by the way Donnie
Yen's going to be in it who do you know
from it man for one of the greatest
martial artists in the world oh also
Hiroki hiroyoki Sonata is going to be in
it one of the great Japanese martial
artists in the world and you what'd you
think and also Marcos are all who's uh
yes martial arts Legend that's right I
got to think about it oh yeah let me
think about it hang on a second oh
um no look I'm a huge fan of all the
John Wick movies I've been bugging the
director to put me in all of them since
the first one and I'm very happy that it
happened to be this one because I think
with all the other action styles that
are coming into the franchise now it's
one of the best action films going but
this is a thing I I was saying to Scott
you know please don't hate me but this
was my first John Wick movie so I'm
saying I know what you look like but I'm
sitting there waiting when is Scott
Adkins going to be in this movie you
don't even make an appearance until an
hour and 13 minutes in believe me I was
watching and you were totally
unrecognizable I want to know what it's
like for you to fight with all of that
fat suit when they first told you you're
going to wear that how did that work for
you
I have to admit my first reaction was
I'm going to be in John Wick 4 and No
One's Gonna know it's me yes but then I
relish the challenge of being able to
create the character from the ground up
and and you know the whole thing that
went with it but the fight scenes yes it
had its difficulties the fat suit wasn't
as heavy as you might think but it was
important for us to sell the weight of
the suit as well so it looks like a
legitimate big guy
um and then you start fighting Keanu
Reeves and in underground basement in
the rain and all the rest of it it was
something are there fans in there is
there water in there what is happening
inside that suit for you oh yeah I've
got calling suits you've got work I've
got a calling soon underneath so I've
got this tube that looks like it's
coming out of my backside which I'll
plug into a bucket of ice and it was
shoot um is that right it's around the
body yeah wow how did it affect your
fighting wearing the fat suit yeah it
wasn't easy yeah yeah but you know I've
been doing martial arts since I was 10
years old so so speaking of that
speaking of the fact that you've been
doing martial arts for the last since
you were 10 years old we'd like a little
demonstration I will be your
demonstration partner is that cool yeah
why do I feel like I'm the one who's
gonna get hit in the face
yeah what could go wrong on live TV yes
let's do that
um all right I've done Taekwondo right
I've done uh I did Taekwondo and karate
pretty much my whole life yeah but it's
been a couple of years I mean I'm also
you will know that one of the most
important things in martial arts when it
comes to kicking yes is chambering the
knee yes and getting the hip into the
correct position right so if I was going
to do a side kick with you yeah and I
hope that your trousers aren't too tight
I would make sure that this foot the
toes are pointing this way on the back
foot so that my hip is in the correct
position I would chamber my knee and I
would do the side kick and so I would
bang There we go mate
one more time
and he didn't crack his pants
yeah that was the important part okay so
let's talk about that spinning you did a
spinning back kick in the film wearing
that fat suit and I thought that was to
me the most impressive thing that I saw
because I'm thinking to myself and you
sold the weight so let's do that scene
or let's do that move and I will be your
I know I'm not in the union for stunt
somebody glad somebody gets kicked in
the head that's right so that's gonna be
nice
choreography okay screen fighting 101.
if we can bring that camera this way a
little bit okay okay I'll put you into
position so if we were making the movie
right and you're John Wick yeah and I'm
gonna do a spinning back kick ready what
I would do I had to do a switch stance
like that just set it up and then I'm
going to bring the kick across here okay
and you're going to react accordingly
are you ready ready to react accordingly
go let's go
[Laughter]
you got good at this when you were 13 11
you got mugged and you thought I will
never let this happen to me again is
that is that a true story that is a true
story uh I turned the garage into a dojo
it was a place for my dad's motorbike
and that quickly got shifted aside and
had a shrine to Bruce Lee and the
machiwara and the punch Bagon yeah I
just decided that was never going to
happen to me again and I was in there
every night training trained in at least
six different types of martial art do I
have that right many martial arts yes
wow and this film for martial arts fans
has all styles displayed you've got
karate Taekwondo Sumo is even on display
there oh yeah the director of the John
Wick move is I mean he's a martial arts
encyclopedia and he's amazing he's an
incredible martial artist himself well
thank you for stretching my friends
very impressive very cool amazing thank
you very much that was awesome thank you
for the demonstration we appreciate it
John Wick chapter 4 opens in theaters
Nationwide on Friday